just feel very self-conscious i feel
like there's a camera pointed right in
my face
i'll get past it i'll get past it i'm
these these are all champagne problems
i'm not i'm not really complaining i
just i feel like [ __ ] yeah you're like i
just [ __ ] i'm just i'm i'm tired i just
got back from europe where i was
watching the football team that i own
uh play and you know and the first class
i gotta look i don't want to complain
here but
you know it's just not first class it's
just not the same as private you know
it's great i had my own pod but it was
one of those pods in the middle where
you're right next to somebody else's pod
you know what i mean it's you want to be
on the pods on the side where you're
just totally alone and isolated you know
and i had a pod and it was next to a guy
and i could hear him
breathing and it just i don't know you
guys
kept asking me do you want something is
there something else we can bring you
sir and i'm like hey leave me alone well
also but wait could you grab me a
champagne i mean that'd be great yes yes
literally champagne problem